cloud data proc is a fast easy to use
fully managed cloud service for running
Apache spark and hibachi tube clusters
in a simpler more cost-efficient way
operations that used to take hours or
even days now take seconds or minutes
instead create cloud data proc clusters
quickly and resize them at any time so
you don't have to worry about your data
pipelines outgrowing your clusters data
proc doesn't just provide you with a
spark our dude cluster with built-in
integrations to other GCP services you
have a powerful and complete platform
for data processing analytics and
machine learning this QuickStart shows
you how to use the Google cloud platform
to create a Google Cloud Data proc
cluster run a simple Apache spark job in
the cluster then modify the number of
workers in the cluster this lab is part
of the baseline data ml and AI quest on
quick labs completing all the labs in
this quest earns you this badge to
recognize your new skills you can show
off your badge on your resume or social
media channels next on our quest data
prep QuickStart although you don't need
your own GCP account to work on these
labs if you're ready to get started use
the link below to receive a $300 GCP
credit
[Music]